Howard Beck Bleacher Report's senior NBA
writer joins us and I share in your pain
and your misery and your anger and your
frustration Howard because every year at
this time I say the same thing the media
should not be voting on the all-nba
teams so why is the media voting on the
all-nba teams good morning Dan it's
complicated or at least my own feelings
on it are complicated so let me make it
clear on this level
I don't mind us being involved as voters
although that has other implications too
even if there were no money attached the
league needs a voting body that is as
impartial as possible people can scoff
if they want is whether or not we're
impartial and make good judgments blah
blah blah we are a better voting body
than the players are the core the
coaches and the people want to debate
that they can but I don't think there's
much discussion there and the league has
the media do it over those other options
for a reason what the problem for me
really is this that in the last CBA
negotiated a few years back they created
the Supermax and to decide how to
qualify for the Supermax the league
lawyers and the union lawyers decided to
attach it to things like all MVA and MVP
and Defensive Player of the Year and
that if you achieve certain of these
marks within a certain span you'd be
eligible for a bigger contract so that
teams had a better tool to try to keep
say Kevin Durant from leaving Oklahoma
which is what spurred that discussion at
the bargaining table in the first place
well so what happened as a result they
ended up tying tens of millions of
dollars to awards that are decided by us
in the media putting us in a just an
awful position we should not be as clear
spot we absolutely positively should not
be as media folks covering the league
put in a position to determine what any
of these guys make and if it's just you
know the awards themselves people can
say well even before they put this in
the CBA you could say that guys winning
certain honors probably helped them at
the bargaining cat's fine if it's just a
negotiating point but you know the great
great players are and what they earn or
what they should are value that anyway
but specifically tying bonuses or a
different kind of contract a
her contract two awards voted on by us
puts us in a terrible spot
I wish they'd never done it I've told
them that not that my opinion matters to
NBA and Union lawyers well I've been
yelling too from the mountaintops about
another thing is that we got to stop
with it you have to have a Center two
forwards and two guards I want to have
the 15 best players I don't need to have
rudy gobert make third team all-nba he's
not one of the top 15 players and plus
Kevin Durant at some time could be
listed as you know a center or draymond
Green could or Steph could be a to which
James Harden you know we got to stop
with these designations because their
their position list now in the NBA amen
and Bob Ryan made a great point on
Twitter the other day there's a funny
setting Bob Ryan made a great I love
that Bob Ryan is on Twitter I love it
but but Bob got on Twitter speaking from
from the NBA mountaintops and he has
seen all of it in the entire evolution
of the game saying listen folks Steph
Curry is not a point guard and it's not
an insult he's just a great scorer and
shooter and in a guard who happens to
also be really good with the ball in his
hands and on that team frankly you know
draymond Green
plays a lot of point forward he handles
a lot of the play making and at times
Kevin Durant when he's healthy handles a
lot of play making and so our old
designations of point guard shooting
guard small forward power forward and
especially in this era they just don't
feel that relevant and I'm with you and
Rachel Nichols has made the point loudly
on the jump as well that especially for
all NBA having the top 15 players in the
league is more important than carving
out designations for you know old labels
that don't feel as relevant today and
and yeah I'm with you having to stick
three centers on there even with even
though the revolution the the center
position has become revolutionized it's
it's a you know it this is not the days
where you know Jamal mcclure makes the
all-star team because you just needed a
center but the NBA has already
eliminated the center from the all-star
ballot did it years ago yeah it's still
on the all-nba ballot is beyond me got
any problem with some bran third team no
I voted him third team myself so I
clearly am NOT going to contradict
myself today
here's the thing his numbers start there
because the numbers are the most always
the most important thing right like
defense matters a lot of things matter a
guy stats or where we start these
discussions let's not say otherwise
LeBron stats across the board like
twenty eight eight and seven or twenty
eight seven seven wherever it was very
close to where they were a season ago
his efficiency down a little bit but
still better than 99% of the NBA and yes
he missed a bunch of games and yes the
Lakers missed the playoffs he still
LeBron freakin James I can't leave him
off the all-nba ballot I just if he
listened if he'd only played 40 games if
he'd fallen below a certain threshold
yeah I think he played I think you play
55 that's getting really close to where
I'm uncomfortable and I wasn't that
comfortable but he's LeBron James
it's a years from now we would think
it's ludicrous that he wasn't all NBA I
also you know you start to look at this
situation with LeBron and he's out he's
out recruiting it's like he's a college
coach out there recruiting to try to get
players I want to know what the
recruiting pitch is for by LeBron James
to get these players to think about the
Lakers yeah that's a fascinating one I
would love to see his powerpoint
presentation I imagine it has something
to do with you know Sun and palm trees
and a whole lot of banners and you know
and come play with me because you know I
recently went to eight straight finals
and I'm still putting up pretty good
numbers as Howard Beck just pointed out
I you know listen obviously he's going
to have to it you know gloss over all
the weirdness and dysfunction that's
going on with that franchise this season
in particular the last couple of months
but the formula is basically the same
you know if you play with LeBron James
we saw for an eight-year stretch if you
with you or his teammate you are
enjoying a very nice long playoff run
and making bonuses and getting a chance
at a championship and I listen to me
that still should be the most persuasive
argument irrespective of Magic Johnson
and Rob polenka and coaching changes and
all that other stuff best player in the
game it feels like is almost week to
week that you know two weeks ago
was the Greek freak Steph Curry had a
run as well in the Portland series Kevin
Durant had a little bit of Iran now it's
Kawhi Leonard's turn who's the best
player in the game you know but back to
the LeBron discussion I think everybody
has just decided that we have to crown
somebody new because LeBron is not
playing and that's fine like if we want
to make this a discussion well listen as
long as he's on the shelf and he's not
in this postseason for the first time in
14 years and I was story about that up
on bleacher report right now
as long as you got on the board let's
pick somebody else but I would say let's
pick him with the understanding that as
soon as next season starts the ones
right back there like there's nothing he
did this season other than missing the
playoffs which has a lot more to do with
the Lakers roster than with him so I
still think by default or at least by
the one who's earned it over the long
haul and still has it would be him if
he's healthy but if he's off to the side
for the moment I would have gone with
Kevin Durant but now he's hurt so are we
talking about the best player who still
actually playing comes back but also
look at Golden State this isn't a small
sample size size Howard we're without
him
what are they like 31 and 4 I know that
I don't think they're better with
without him I think they're different
without him I think they play
differently without him he's the great
luxury item which should be his nickname
but but I I just I think Steph Curry is
more valuable to that team than Kevin
Durant will ever be it's complicated
right because they want a championship
before Durant got there they lost the
championship before Durant got there he
has been the Finals MVP the last two
years and absolutely was the right
choice both years and earned it
and I'm not sure that they win those two
championships without him and you know
look it's his his skillset and his
uniqueness it was so they went out and
got it for a reason and the reason was
when they lost to the Cavs in the finals
there all kinds of caveats we can place
on that series but the bottom line was
they didn't have anybody who could just
manufacture out of thin air the way that
LeBron and Kyrie could for the Cavaliers
and getting Kevin Durant meant they had
somebody that went
all else fails when they're beautiful
offense breaks down when all the ball
and player movement breaks down if
someone just got to pull something out
of there you know where Kevin Durant can
do that in a way that nobody they had
could and so I think he has been
essential to them a luxury item yes
especially in the regular season maybe
even a luxury item in the first couple
rounds of the playoffs but I think in
the finals in particular that's when
Durant has mattered most of them but I
do agree that the heart of their
identity and the guy who makes them tick
the most is still Steph Curry and I
think during the regular season you saw
that when curry was out that they didn't
win at his high a percentage with a team
that was that was Durant generated
because step is that important to their
style of play and then the way that the
ball moves klay Thompson underrated or
overrated you know if he doesn't make
the all-nba teams and he didn't now I
feel like kind of underrated and people
are trying to you know pick away at all
the different things of this season well
you know he's he shot poorly the first
couple months or his defense wasn't
locked in my gosh alright so you know
the caveat here again I put klay
Thompson on my own be a 13 so my
response years is obvious I believed he
was worthy of all-nba this year and so
therefore yeah I feel like if he didn't
make it which he didn't that he's become
a little underrated I think he's more
underappreciated I think people
understand his talent or his value and
his incredible shooting and his defense
and his versatility on the defensive end
I think he they they maybe rate him
properly but don't value him properly if
I can make that distinction they just
they're not showing enough appreciation
for what he does and within a role and
he could do a lot more somewhere else if
he wanted to I don't suspect that he
will but I think he could be an even
bigger time scorer on another team which
leads me to the Houston Rockets
situation where the report is on the
athletic that apparently Chris Paul and
James Harden had words during the game
Game six and after the game Game six and
then they went their separate ways
I understand frustration when a closeout
game
with Golden State eliminating them but
if Chris Paul who is always complaining
you know he's saying to the coach and
you know ball movement and you signed up
for this you know you had a year left on
your deal when you went to Houston you
signed up for it you can't all of a
sudden in game six go I think we need to
change our offensive style here feels
like it's a little late in the game and
then these two are stuck with each other
you know Chris Paul got that
unbelievable deal that they overpaid for
him so he's there you know for thick or
thin good or bad what do you think yeah
I agree with everything you just said
Dan he forced his way there that's where
he wanted to be he wanted to play with
James Harden he and into that even even
on style of play let's talk about that
for a second because I wrote about this
a year ago Mike D'Antoni was always all
about ball and player movement and the
ball finds energy and all this that was
how that was his mantra in Phoenix when
they were at their best and everywhere
since and Mike D'Antoni adapted out of
necessity and because he wanted to win
because he had two incredible isolation
guards who loved to dominate the ball in
Harden and Chris Paul so they changed
Mike's offense essentially your horse
Mike to adapt and what they've done
since then all good and bad is about
what Chris Paul wants to do the way he
wants to play and the way James Harden
wants to play so they are completely
responsible as a all-star duo for that
style and if Chris Paul is all of a
sudden yo you act that James Harden is
dominating the ball too much I don't
know what to tell him not only did you
buy into this but you're part of that
style you're you're you are part of why
the Rockets moved this direction instead
of Mike D'Antoni's old offense so yeah
little hypocritical but I also
understand it and listen the more that
they have failed and you know failure is
a strong term for a team that's know
made some pretty nice playoff runs and
was within a couple minutes of the
finals a year ago but to the extent that
they have fallen short of the finals and
if there are flaws people I think are
focusing more and more now on the well
hardens amazing and this gets them to a
certain point but does there need to be
a little bit more balance on that
Rockets team to get where they want to
go and
spend the lesson for MBA teams for you
know eons you know that was even what
Phil Jackson had to convince Michael
Jordan of way back in the day that you
know guys have to be involved that there
has to be more than a one-man show
Howard great stuff have a great weekend
thanks for joining us always appreciate
it Dan thank you wish you the best
that's Howard Beck Bleacher Report's
senior NBA writer if you missed any of
the interviews from the Mercedes the AMG
mancave go to the Dan Patrick show app
you can watch or listen from inside the
Mercedes AMG mancave Mercedes AMG
driving performance for more Dan Patrick
show tune in the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]